these PVC tube instruments that is a
three dollar piece of plastic you can
buy at Lowe's and that is part of what's
exciting about how would someone a
musical being look at this for the first
time what would they want to do with it
the instruments come about I think
everyone is a little bit different
anybody can bring an idea to the table
our tone mill was one of our blue men
that drew a sketch the concept of this
is that you have different tubes and
then the length of the tube is creating
the pitch the note by having two you can
have a chord potentially if you're you
can use a stick or you can use another
tube that has its own note to create a
chord this is another piece another
instrument that we're working on for a
piece that's being developed about
feedback through the speaker on one end
there's a microphone on the other end
and you when you put a microphone at a
speaker it causes feedback and with the
pipe we can tune it to be different
notes
where the struggle is is that everyday
we walk in the notes are totally
different we're now being inspired by
the challenge to try and find a way to
make this actually workable and tunable
every night
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're trying to find a instruments
that could drone in a similar way as
didgeridoo but obviously have different
playing aspects and something that was
again theatrically it's something that
was visual and had a lot of action to it
it's kind of inspired by a hurdy-gurdy
style instrument and you're bowing this
and then changing the note with this
lever
[Music]
similar concept we've got to hire
strings here just music wire something
you have on a piano and this wheel that
you spin and then very sophisticated we
have zip ties cut to a little over a
half an inch and when you when you
rotate this you are plucking the strings
and then we have this slider which is
fretting and we've come up with our own
musical language here the blue men speak
in colors and shapes when reading music
[Music]
so we basically took a vibraphone and
split it apart on to a separate sort of
playable platform that can be a lot more
visual as a as an instrument so these
are actual vibraphone keys and then
there's pickups underneath each one so
that we can now run it through whatever
fun petals we want to do we want to run
it through
[Music]